you've probably heard about some of
these bizarre legal defenses the twinkie
defense what could that possibly mean or
if you've been on reddit you might have
engaged in a thought experiment about
what would happen if one of two
identical twins committed a murder they
look exactly the same as their twin and
they share the same dna well the thing
is these legal defenses have actually
been made and some were actually
successful well
sort of successful it depends on who you
ask it partially look if the law is
complicated i don't know what to tell
you but it did
so stop me if you've heard this one dmx
the rapper plays one of his songs in
court and receives a reduced sentence
well this actually happened in april of
2021 the world lost earl simmons better
known as the stage name dmx the
successful rapper songwriter and actor
dmx undoubtedly had tremendous impact on
music and pop culture but as often the
case for entertainers with fame and
fortune follows addiction and a litany
of legal troubles and since 1986 dmx has
been jailed 30 times for a variety of
offenses including robbery assault
carjacking drug possession pretending to
be a federal agent and tax evasion but
the reason we are talking about dmx
today is for the unique defense offered
by x's attorneys at his sentencing
hearing for his tax case and in what
sounds like a contrived plot to an 80s
movie no one actually saw the day was
saved in part thanks to
the power of hip-hop
it's true i got the bars like candy but
spitting bars like me will get you all
up in the grammy
no no not like that definitely not like
that but in july of 2017 federal
prosecutors charged dmx with 14 counts
of tax fraud the government alleged that
dmx owed 1.7 million in unpaid taxes
from income earned between 2002 and 2005
and had failed to file taxes from 2010
to 2015 where dmx had made at least 2.3
million pro tip not legal advice
always file your taxes especially for a
five-year period where you're making
millions of dollars but in november of
2017 dmx changed his plea to guilty and
prior to sentencing prosecutors were
seeking the maximum penalty for five
years in prison so enter the
father-daughter legal team of murray
don't worry murray richmond and stacy
richmond who decided to try a novel
music-based strategy to convince u.s
district judge jed rakoff to be lenient
at dmx's sentencing theory murray
richmond argued that his client suffered
a nightmarish childhood which had led to
repeated encounters with the law at an
early age and set him on a bad path as
an adult to illustrate his point murray
requested that judge rakoff watch his
client's music video for dmx's hit song
slippin that lyrically describes his
traumatic upbringing growing up dmx was
abandoned by his father lived in extreme
poverty endured severe psychological and
physical abuse from his mother and her
boyfriends who knocked out dmx's teeth
and left prominent scars on his face as
a young boy and then was introduced to
drugs at 14 years old murray argued that
watching this video would show how dmx
was not a bad person just that his
difficult upbringing meant he was simply
not prepared for the responsibility of
having lots of money the judge agreed to
watch the video and after listening to
the song judge rakhoff remarked that in
the eyes of the court dmx was a good man
noting quote in many ways he's his own
worst enemy judge rakoff then gave dmx a
reduced sentence for one year in prison
and ordered him to pay 2.3 million in
back taxes after sentencing dmx's
co-counsel stacey richmond explained the
rationale for playing slip in for the
court this was about the humanity of one
person reaching out to everyone else and
it's not about getting a path a pass
it's about getting a path and after
learning about this case i'm gonna have
to talk to my clients about their
bizarre lack of hit songs to support
their cases i mean i can't do all the
work for you but that brings us to the
twinkie defense which is a very derisive
term for a thing that actually happened
though it is incredibly misunderstood
the most common legal strategy for
defending murder suspects is to deny all
allegations and force the government to
prove every factual element of their
case but when there is no dispute that
the defendant committed the crime
defense counsel will often shift to the
defendant's mental state to show why the
defendant is not legally responsible for
the crime and at a minimum deserves a
less severe charge than first degree
murder and such was the case with dan
white a former san francisco city
supervisor who assassinated then-mayor
george moscone and supervisor harvey
milk in a rampage at city hall turned
himself into the police and then
confessed to the crime well i'm
definitely a law and order i campaigned
very hard on what i consider to be the
number one priority not only for my
district but for san francisco and that
is to make this a safe city now this has
been the subject of several movies but
here's the pertinent actual background
on january 8 1978 harvey milk became the
first openly gay elected official in the
history of california a fervent advocate
for gay rights milk's first official act
on the board was to introduce a bill
which passed almost unanimously
outlawing discrimination based on sexual
orientation in employment housing and
public accommodations milk's famously
brash brand of liberal politics
frequently brought him into conflict
with that of conservative fellow
supervisor dan white a 32 year old
former police officer and firefighter
for example white was the lone
dissenting vote against milk's
non-discrimination ordinance tensions
between the two began to reach a boiling
point when milk cast a deciding vote in
favor of opening a halfway home in
white's district for troubled
adolescents white stated that he felt
betrayed by milk who had initially
promised to oppose the halfway home and
soon became disillusioned with the board
of supervisors 11 months into his tenure
white abruptly resigned from the board
on november 10 1978 white claimed that
he could not support his family on a
9600 salary and announced that he was
leaving politics for good four days
later in response to pressure from
conservative-leaning police and business
groups who feared that the mayor would
appoint a replacement who would create a
6-5 liberal conservative split white
sought to withdraw his resignation
although mayor masconi initially agreed
to give white his job back the mayor
changed course following an outpouring
of outrage from white's constituents who
blasted him as ineffective and
inattentive on november 27 1978 the
mayor was set to appoint community
activist don jorenzi as supervisor
angered that his plan to return to the
board was thwarted white then showed up
at city hall slipped into a window to
avoid metal detectors and confronted the
mayor at his office when the mayor
refused white's demand to be reappointed
white proceeded to shoot and kill the
mayor execution style he then walked
down the hall and murdered harvey milk
as well murdering his former colleague
both moscone and milk immediately died
from their injuries soon then acting
mayor dianne feinstein made the stunning
announcement to the press both mayor
moscone
and supervisor harvey milk
have been shot
and killed
the suspect
the supervisor van wyk
later that day white visited his former
police precinct to turn himself in then
confessed to the killings in a recorded
interview and then he started kind of
smirking because he knew he knew
too bad and then i just got all flushed
and
hot and
i shot him the assassinations roiled the
city of san francisco resulting in an
outpouring of spontaneous support and
mourning from the community and at trial
the defense counsel for white argued
that white's long-standing and untreated
depression gave him what's called
diminished capacity such that he could
not distinguish between right and wrong
and thus lacked the required intent to
be found guilty of premeditated first
degree murder remember that the
difference between first second and
third degree murder usually depends on
the mental state of the accused dr
martin blinder one of the five expert
witnesses called by the defense
testified in the days leading up to the
killings white known for being focused
on personal health and fitness cast
aside his normal habits grew stubble and
in lieu of his normal healthy diet
indulged in junk food blinder testified
that white's excessive consumption of
junk food including twinkies which were
only mentioned in passing were evidence
of his depressed state that had
exacerbated his already existing
depression and the jury bought this
diminished capacity defense and white
was convicted of voluntary manslaughter
rather than first-degree murder he
served five years in prison of a seven
year sentence less than two years later
white returned to san francisco and
committed suicide outrage after the
verdict led to a series of violent
events in san francisco that would be
known as the white knight riots and
following intense negative publicity in
1982 california abolished the term
diminished capacity as a legal defense
and replaced it with something called
diminished actuality under this new
standard evidence of mental illness is
admissible to show a defendant lacked
the specific intent to commit the
specific crime in which they were
charged as opposed to the prior standard
that could be used to show that the
defendant lacks all capacity to have any
specific intent to commit any crime and
as you can imagine many people were
upset about the outcome of the white
trial which is where the twinkie defense
name comes in in stories covering the
trial san francisco satirist paul
krasner played up the angle of the
twinkie and claims that he may have even
coined the term the twinkie defense
derisive reporters covering the trial
seized on the testimony made in passing
that white had eaten twinkies in the
days leading up to the murders adopted
the twinkie defense framing which led to
decades of misunderstanding and due to
this misreporting in the press much of
the public erroneously believed that
white's lawyers had argued that twinkies
drove white to commit the murder in
reality white's lawyers argued that the
junk food was a symptom of his
diminished capacity not the cause but
this misconception that white received a
lesser charge by claiming junk food made
him commit murder which was repeated at
the end of the 2008 biopic milk persists
to this day nevertheless the actual
defense advanced was still controversial
for successfully reducing white's
charges from murder to manslaughter
since then some commentators have argued
that the so-called twinkie defense was
less pivotal to white's defense than was
the relatively conservative jury who
possibly supported and sympathized with
a former supervisor it was reported at
the time that when the jury listened to
dan white's recorded murder confession
several of them actually wept and today
the term the twinkie defense has become
a derisive catch-all label for
improbable legal defenses though like
the ones that we're talking about in
this video and during the oral argument
in the supreme court case of u.s vs
gonzales lopez the late justice antonin
scalia famously referenced the twinkie
defense to suggest that the right to
select one's own council is perhaps more
important than the right to have
effective assistance of counsel the
justice argued that quote i don't want a
competent lawyer i want a lawyer to get
me off i want a lawyer to invent the
twinkie defense i want to win and now we
know why lawyers get accused of being
unethical but now let's talk about one
crazy legal hypothetical that you'd
think you'd only cover in law school but
actually happened in real life what
happens when an identical twin commits
murder if like me you were raised on tv
in the 1990s then you know that the
surefire formula to ensure wacky hijinks
is to introduce twins into any situation
have them switch places and then let the
shenanigans unfold remember those
classic episodes where tia and tamara
switch places so they could take tests
or marry kate and ashley switch places
to get their parents together and who
can forget that time that zach and cody
were arrested for drug trafficking in
malaysia but narrowly escaped the death
penalty when authorities couldn't tell
them apart oh wait a minute that's my
bad that actually wasn't a special
episode of the suite life with zach and
cody that was a real case where
twin-based shenanigans actually
prevented brothers from being executed
in 2003 malaysian authorities arrested
27-year-old identical twins sathis raj
and sabaris raj for trafficking large
amounts of opium and cannabis which in
malaysia carries a mandatory penalty of
death by hanging the police had caught
one twin red-handed taking a car load of
drugs to another house which only he had
the key and then shortly thereafter the
other twin arrived and was promptly
arrested at trial the judge acknowledged
that the first brother who was arrested
with the key was the only one with
access to the drug house and therefore
was the only one the state could be able
to prove was guilty of drug trafficking
beyond reasonable doubt the problem that
due to the twins identical features it
was impossible for the arresting
officers to determine which twin had
been initially arrested with a key to
the drug house so further complicating
the case the twins refused to admit to
any crimes refused to testify against
each other and the dna evidence was
inconclusive unable to identify the twin
originally arrested in possession of the
drugs the judge acquitted both men in
explaining her decision to acquit the
brothers high court judge zahari ibrahim
noted quote this is a very unique case
as they are identical twins even the dna
evidence could not prove anything as dna
could be either sautis or sabarish's i
can't be calling the wrong twin to enter
his defense i can't be sending the wrong
person to the gallows or to explain this
case using only simpson's references he
can't kill anybody if he doesn't know
which one's the real krusty
now i would like to tell you that this
case is an outlier and that there isn't
some identical twin exception to criming
unfortunately convicting individuals
with identical twin siblings remains an
ongoing dilemma for law enforcement more
often than you would think suspects have
been acquitted or have charges dropped
when authorities can't prove which twin
is guilty one problem in these cases is
that eyewitnesses who struggle to
identify the twin that committed the
actual crime for example in 2011 19 year
old orlando nimbard was charged with
shooting and killing a man outside of an
arizona nightclub however when evidence
revealed that his twin brother brandon
was at the scene prosecutors dropped the
charges when the witnesses were unable
to identify which brother pulled the
trigger so as you can imagine reasonable
doubt can be built right into these
cases this isn't a legal issue per se
it's an evidentiary issue you have to
prove your case beyond a reasonable
doubt and if you can't identify which
twin it was then you have a pretty
uphill climb now this video isn't over
yet there is an extended version of this
video over at nebula thanks to today's
sponsor curiositystream who is running a
42 off sale for the holidays here is one
criminal defense that i definitely
couldn't put on youtube how lorena
bobbitt gone off
i mean
why lorena bobbitt was found not guilty
and i am thrilled to announce my first
nebula original bad law words good it is
a long-form documentary where i explore
all the most common legal and linguistic
comments that people throw around in
everyday life incorrectly it's a
hilarious romp through legal
misunderstandings logical fallacies and
law and order parodies and it's only on
nebula which you can get for free with
today's sponsor curiosity stream because
nebula is a place where we can
experiment with content and release
things that we couldn't put on youtube
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream because they are the
go-to source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational content on the
internet they even have an entire
section devoted to unsolved mysteries
and crimes so if you like my videos
you'll love the stuff on curiositystream
and we worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity with a link in the
description you'll also get a nebula
subscription for free and to be clear
that nebula subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member and right now
curiosity stream is offering 42 off
their annual plans that's the best sale
they've ever run and it's less than 12
for the entire year for both curiosity
stream and nebula so if you click on the
link in the description or the link
that's on screen right now you'll get
both curiosity stream and nebula for 42
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legal eagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly and it's the only way to see my
documentary bad law words good so just
click on the link that's on screen right
now plus clicking on that link really
helps out this channel and while you're
at it click on this playlist with all of
my other legal entertainment videos so
click on this video or i'll see you in
court